earlier today you mentioned that you see
tenacity as being one of the number one
things that's driven people ahead in
this business
aside from talent or it just you know
connections whatever tenacity is the
number one thing of the people the two
of you have known how many years would
you say it's taken these individuals to
have a quote Hollywood career I would
rather not answer that okay and I'll
tell you why because I don't see any
benefit to anybody hearing the answer
because if I say it's quick in the hopes
that they'll be encouraged it won't take
long and they're taking longer than that
they could get discouraged and quit if I
say it's a long time and they're just
starting they could get discouraged and
quit so I rather just say it happens
when it happens but maybe mark is
willing to well your question is how
long have we seen it take you know it's
this there's a variety there's a wide
variety it's a right variety and it's
and I think getting back to Michaels
thing about tenacity tenacity is
important whether it takes you ten years
to get a script made I mean Dallas
buyers club took 20 years before they
got it made so there's tenacity for the
producers and all that they had the
script a long time before that and some
things happen quickly having it within a
year or something like that but I think
you know the important thing is how much
do you believe in what you're doing and
if you believe I mean I have some
projects I'm working on and I call I
don't care how long it takes I just want
to get it done you know in other words
if you believe in something if you
believe in the project you're doing
that's that's what's gonna make that
time period not matter
did you know anybody's at home I would
have been working on this for two years
three years five years I mean I hear
people say oh I've been working on the
script for eight years I said great I've
been working on for one year great I
don't care how long they've been working
like I'm much more interested in their
why they want to make this movie why
they've written this script what what's
what's driving them to get this
particular film made or even in my case
with directors why why what's driving
you to get this one actor involved you
know because you can't make it without
him it fine you know in other words
that's what I'm much more interested I
don't care how long I think a time frame
if you get into time frames it time
frames are good for the newspapers you
know how long this took and you know how
quickly this happened and there's always
the instant stardom which is never
instant you know if you really know this
story then there's you know the long
range you know fighting for how many 20
years to get a movie made that's good
for the newspapers it's not helpful I
agree with Michael to the artist at all
it also depends there's a difference
between saying I've been working on this
project for 12 years
and saying I've only been working on
this project for 12 years I mean Dallas
buyers club may have taken that long but
Matthew McConaughey didn't stop acting
and the producers didn't stop doing so I
think that's a pitfall when you say I'm
going to just keep hammering and
hammering and hammering at this one
script and one script and not move on to
others just get it done and to to some
level and either but be ready to move on
I I think a goal should be two scripts a
year certainly especially if you're
trying to launch your career in the
early days don't get don't make one idea
so precious that you're just going to
keep reworking and reworking it or keep
getting stuck and blocked and not
wanting to do anything because you put
all your eggs in that basket and I think
another important thing too because the
way you phrase your question was how the
way I heard it was how long have you
seen it take for someone to make it and
I think that's not quite the way I would
suggest looking at it is because then it
becomes what's the definition of making
it have you made it when you finished
your first script and you had that
experience or have you made it when you
got an agent is it the first dollar you
make but what if you option it for a
dollar have you made
I think a better choice for a writer or
anyone I think in the industry is to
make your goal specific and just say
what is the next step I need to get to
that feels just out of reach right now
and so just say I my focus right now is
to finish my screenplay and don't be
thinking about how long is it going to
be before I'm a success
that's just amorphous and elusive just
say my goal right now is to finish this
script and apply yourself to that and
when that's done then say my goal now is
to finish a second script and to pursue
an agent with this first one and make
the goals more finite and specific and
shorter as you sort of go up the rungs
of that ladder yeah I think I think I
also have to look at because what you
said Karen I'm gonna quote you Hollywood
success didn't you say that I forget
that because that doesn't mean I mean
it's I think that's unfortunate
finishing a script is a success I want
to write this story I finish it there's
the whole story forget the quality that
in other words how you label success
okay that was successful now if you go
with what Mike Michaels saying to
scripts a year right by then at the end
of the year I've got two scripts up Wow
two successes in other words that is
success also looking at from a directing
point of view but also writing okay
here's what I want to do I want to
direct a feature film a big feature film
great how are you gonna do it I don't
know what are you doing meanwhile what
could you getting back to what what is
manageable and just only just a little
bit I'm gonna do this little short film
I've got a five minute film great let's
do that while you're pursuing the bigger
thing why knowing that aren't believing
that everything I do every script I
write every little film I make every
little project I do I get something that
someone wants me to direct a commercial
for the internet do that everything I'm
is going to take me closer to where I
want to be because I'm gonna learn from
every single experience something and
maybe I'm a makeup short film and it may
be a
has asked her I mean I know the last
short film I made I want to look at it I
go oh I made so many mistakes of that
but that's the learning process in other
words keep working keep writing keep
writing scripts and knowing that every
script you write it's gonna make you a
better writer every film you make it's
gonna make it make you a better
filmmaker even if you say I'm just gonna
take out my little camera like this
little Canon we're shooting I'm gonna go
out oh I have to tell you a story I was
teaching once it's the same story I was
gonna teach you once in England and I
was teaching at this big film school and
they're all these some famous directors
there and television directors Abed well
so some people who are just starting out
and is that a film school so their film
students there too and there was also
this young boy who was 12 years old
taking this weekend workshop I noticed
this little boy sitting there and it was
fine then Cara's teaching and at one
point he came up to me and he asked me a
question about filmmaking I forget what
the question yeah ask me something about
directing and I said okay he says yeah
he says I'm gonna make a film this
weekend next weekend I said really he
says yeah I'm gonna shoot the film
actually gonna shoot the whole film next
week he says yeah yeah he says it's only
a 10-minute film I said I see and you
have the budget for it he says yeah yeah
and he had I think ten pounds or
something the cost of the roll of film
of tape that would run ten minutes and
he had a whole film figured out how he's
gonna do it in one take and go out in
the weekend and shoot one movie and it
would be done and I remember after a
little later this summer I announced
everybody there's a filmmaker in there
in the room that's going to make a film
next weekend and no he'll be done next
weekend and he has the budget people
really what but so I introduced him but
it's sort of set the bar high for
everybody this kids going out and he's
doing it he had come to take the seminar
and then he's gonna go out and make a
movie and he figured out in ten minutes
story it's gonna be one take and he'll
be done he'll learn so much from that in
other words if you're going to be and
this is a lot of what Michaels saying if
you want to be doing it to be doing it
that is success if you get up I have for
me a unlimited a minimum of a number of
words I have to write every day and I
know and my camp
bless his little heart tells me how many
words I've written and I feel very happy
when I hit that that success whether the
writing was good or not doesn't matter
it's so I think we have to you know just
keep going just keep moving so don't
look at it as a final destination but
it's little little pinpoints on a map
yeah it went here great and most
Hollywood success is you know it's a
fluke I mean most films that are made
don't we never see most of them are
terrible
there were every once in a while a good
one comes up but it's a fluke but
Hollywood success is a fluke I mean
there is a lot of good luck a lot of
good fortune but everybody of a
successful director has been working
really really hard all right so just
measure success in small little bite
size rather than you know an Academy
Award or something crap like that
you